mais alors comme j'ai lu pas mal de
coups durs l'aï lu porto rico il ya eu
droit si on va vous faire l'interview
dernier coup en ne bouge pas pendant le
single en f1 pendant le king alessandro
ballan guinée mois un dernier coup dur
porterait comporterait dans les coups de
foudre
il ya longtemps des télécoms de 24,4 au
dessinateur qui dure dans les coups de
gueule et coups de fil
dernier coup de fil que tu es pour le
courrier picard tout à l'heure ah ouais
de l'aéroport pourquoi les 3e aéroport
qui veulent installer sa bosse et le
royal c'est lui qui dirigeait le pays je
me lève je voudrais tellement de choses
avant feriez quoi par exemple si vous
étiez premier ministre la première
décision vous prendriez geneviève déjà
je serai plus là bourse qui mènerait le
monde
ah ouais ça déjà parce que c'est
l'argent qui est le monde en ce moment
et moi je suis révolté de voir de plus
en plus de misère de est ça qui me
révolte aussi c'est sophie thalmann
quand je pense qu'elle gagne et des fois
dans une en une heure ce qu'ils peuvent
cacher des grandes surfaces gagne en un
mois
et moi je trouve que devrait avoir honte
de dire les choses comme ça pour pour
simplement faire payer cash et un
sourire ça vous êtes pour la taxe tobin
j'ai lu avec des pois la taxe tobin
petit pour nos fleurons ça moi ça me dit
ça me hérisse les poils de penser à lui
ronge juste quand tu ta vie ton nouveau
frontaliers
dernier coup de rouge du buissière avec
une non c'était moi je ne veux pas de
ton dans les coups de bluff
elle a dit je paye souvent oui qu'est ce
qui arrange les robes après oui c'est
remettre dans les alpes à moi je choisis
moi toi une fois que c'est fini
il faut quelqu'un remballe qu'est-ce qui
remballe d'image des pièces qui se passe
c'est moi qui conduis qu'est ce qui
conduit pourvu que j'entends la santé
vont compter
geneviève béthune samedi dernier coup de
chapeau
ils entendaient bien tout le temps mais
oui c'est ça qui est bizarre c'est moche
mais c'est vrai qu'avec ce mix de la
coutume des méchants hommes meurent
jamais j'ai élu on se concentre à
dernier qudra à jeu car comment
elle seulement de celui de tous âges
bon
non